going back to it when you were talking
about the we're talking about the jfk uh
um documentary
there's a there's a part of it where
uh the
the ci agent they're talking about
oswald and a part of it in the story uh
where in the documentary they're talking
about the other agent whose name is
thomas arthur valley right thomas arthur
valley very interesting where it shows
you know they were have couple other
attempts on this assassination on
kennedy one of them being november 2nd
in chicago the other one being november
18 in tampa and he's supposed to go on
this 27 mile you know yeah
and then they say you shouldn't do this
this valet guy
ex-marine oswald ex-marine uh was at the
japan base he's at the japan base he
trained on the base there
but in japan cia cuba training same here
he was at a six or seven story building
almost identical to the building
and then the entire time while this is
going on and i'm talking to jim jenkins
i said jim let me ask you a question who
like who do you think was behind this
who do you think caused all of this
and i'm asking them names i said what do
you think about lyndon johnson
and he says i i don't trust lyndon
johnson i said tell me why so you know
the story behind lyndon johnson being
way more ambitious than john f kennedy
and he was so upset with the fact that
these guys took office and behind closed
doors so
from your end when you were doing the
investigation i know jfk wanted to get
rid of cia and lyndon johnson wanted to
go vietnam john f kennedy didn't want to
go vietnam you know these things that
they had
how much do i felt like that documentary
could have gone a little bit deeper on
lbj's motivation what did you learn
about lbj at the end this is a very good
question and i'm
reluctant to point at johnson for the
for the murder as i said at the time in
1991 i do believe totally he was
responsible for the cover-up
because the cover he starts with the
warren commission he does everything
possible and he if you saw that you
remember the documentary
there's even a scene when he's talking
to mcnamara you hear the phone
conversation where he says i didn't
agree with you and the president that we
should go that we should uh uh pull out
of vietnam
he's very very pointed so he i don't
think though he wanted to go to vietnam
i think that
that was on the agenda because we had
already started the process of vietnam
with eisenhower not with kennedy with
eisenhower we started the process of
supporting the french paying for the
french war
so kennedy
fell into the trap he'd sent advisers
not combat troops but he insisted no
combat troops he insisted to the very
end he insisted no combat troops go to
laos either no combat troops are going
to go to cuba that's the reason the bay
of pigs
he was hated by the cuban community
after two three years of this he refused
to fight send american troops into cuba
kennedy unknown what war was knew what
it meant he'd been on that pt boat he'd
seen all the he been at the lower level
and he knew he didn't believe the
generals he he saw the fallacy of this
belief that the generals know everything
he he comes into office the first thing
he's presented with is eisenhower's
psyop plan siop
62 sio p 62 to blow up the world
uh there is a plan you know that they
were going to attack china and moscow
russia
first
and that first strike option was also on
the table it still is in the united
states the first strike option is still
on the table and very much a
consideration in this ukraine debate by
the way because
certainly that's one of the things the
russians fear the most is encirclement
and nato
and
nuclear
nuclear nuclear arms in the polish
romanian and possibly ukrainian hands
there it is single integrated
operational plan it's a wicked plan and
it was devised by people who were
basically paranoid you saw the movie dr
strangelove you saw the military people
as pictured there
can i can i read this to the audience
recording the single interrogator
this was the united states general plan
for nuclear war from 1961 to 2-3 gave
the president united states a range of
targeting options and described launch
procedures and targets set against the
nuclear weapons would be launched to
plan integrate the capabilities of a
nuclear tire
zone
interesting
this is a system this is an industry
this is not
just a plan this is a business
of billions of dollars how much have we
spent since
1947 on our
defense
it's out of proportion to anything we
really it for our defense
it's basically to dominate the world to
have 800 bases in every country
practically we can in the world
and it's a gigantic operation but a lot
of people contractors
uh raython
lockheed martin
make a fortune on this thing a fortune
on this business so
to close this down to start to reduce it
is the hardest thing to do in the world
since jack kennedy was president
no american president has gone close to
even
trying to interfere with
with the military with that system to
really cut back
or at the same time with the interfered
with the intelligence agencies of this
country remember he said very clearly
after the bay of pigs because they had
given him false information and they
betrayed him there he said i'm gonna
we're gonna destroy i'd like to
i'd like to i'd like to shatter the cia
and and
scatter it to the winds i forgot the
exact quote but he certainly made the
effort he fired alan dulles who was the
head of the cia he was a respected
revered figure from the 1950s under
eisenhower his brother was john foster
dollar secretary of state who set this
policy not of neutrality but of
rollback
it wasn't even
containment had been the american policy
towards communism rollback this is what
uh dulles wanted and he want
brinksmanship he believed in
brinksmanship and he and that's what was
going on right now the same people are
back in the state department and giving
that kind of advice to joe biden
but okay we're there now again this
we're potentially in another
cuban missile crisis potentially
going back to this system that existed
uh kennedy was trying to change it and
the moment he went killed the whole
thing changes we keep going all the
presidents they they're they're puppets
basically they they they operate within
a certain parameter they can't touch the
two most important things are the
intelligence agencies and the military
industrial do you two have a similar
opinion on who actually killed jfk
yeah well we haven't gone there yet
what is your opinion i'm curious well
my opinion is is based on what
years of thinking about it but frankly
it can't johnson was a weakling compared
to what we're dealing with here
johnson was a loser he was a vice
president and uh he had a lot of scandal
in his life so he was not in a position
of great strength
which makes him all the more suspect as
a
but he
he would have been very suspect if he
something had happened to kennedy
he
the people who did this
have to be at the very top of the
society they had to be cia and the only
people i could really think work are the
dulles people because he was the king of
the cia and he had although he had been
fired he was still in washington and he
was very active his people were still
there kennedy fired bissell and
and cabell but
the whole
people left in the ci you have to clean
out the whole agency as harriman said
that
you cannot leave those people in place
richard helms became the new
traffic cop he became the new real head
mccone was appointed but he was a
figurehead
helms and and that gang were still there
and those are the guys you really got to
look at because they were
moving the oswalds around the map to
russia that this is what dulles did they
they had they had a program angleton was
another guy james eagleton who ran that
program
putting american defectors into russia
for information we wanted land-based
information we wanted
we didn't we had to spy uh we had uh u2
flights and all that but they wanted
people on the ground they sent over
quite a few defectors
how'd they get how'd they get there and
how they came back is a very interesting
story and of course oswald is hardly
examined he's
he's also given money it's just a
strange strange story we go into it the
fingerprints of intelligence are all
over oswald
it's very clear from uh if you watch
these uh
even the two hour will make that very
clear yeah so if you have that
intelligence uh but even at that level
dulles would not have been
dulles had to be given the go-ahead by
someone else and who the only people i
can think of is the people who basically
run this country
basically east coast financial people
from the establishment and that goes to
a high level and that doesn't mean
everybody they're not sitting around at
a conference room it just means he has
to have a conversation is it oak is it
okay this president is a problem he's
he's antagonized big business uh with
the steel price hike
he's made it very clear his pacifist
tendencies
and his getting along with
these third world countries he's
anti-colonial
very much the irish rebel
this is going to be a problem because
he's going to get elected in 64. and
then his brother his brother robert
who's a tough guy he thought that he
fought the mob he's going to come in 60
and 72 potentially
676. and then there's this other younger
brother teddy who was already in the
senate
and he's going to be next could be a
dynasty they're scared of roosevelt
roosevelt had been there for
16 15 years
15 years of roosevelt this they were
scared a lot of these people were shaken
like my father they didn't want to see
another
renaissance of democratic rule
uh
people's rule they don't believe in
people's democracy they don't believe
the people should run the country no
they want control and
you so that's the whole thing the
eisenhower and reagan are so
anti-roosevelt they they all their
policies are gradually dismantling the
new deal and you see that through the
whole 1980s 90s even now we have some
remnants of the new deal which i think
are very good but they're going to be
under fire they're going to be under
threat so if you enjoyed this little
segment from the podcast click over here
to watch the entire podcast and if
you've not subscribed to the channel
please do so take care everybody
[Music]